china has a problem
its young people aren't having enough
children
[Music]
last year the birth rate fell by almost
20 percent
and at the same time its population is
getting older
this could affect the planet's biggest
power struggle china
versus america and the fight for
economic dominance
china is in its post-covet phase
and it's ready to take on the world
president xi
has ambition to double the size of
china's economy by the middle of the
next decade
officials in the ruling communist party
or ccp
are worried they've not been moving
quickly enough
to grapple with it now china needs to
take
radical steps to change the nature of
its economy
or it risks getting old before it gets
rich
are children of one of the greatest
social experiments in history
china's one child policy from 1979 to
2016
this limited couples to having one child
and this coupled with rising education
and urbanization
dramatically reduced the birth rate now
even though having more than one child
is permitted most people in this
generation would bulk at the idea of
having larger families
or in fang and wang's case any children
at all
[Music]
either
they're not alone even after the one
child policy was relaxed
the birth rate did not rise
significantly and this is one of the
major factors in the changing
shape of chinese society
this represents the chinese population
it used to resemble a pyramid
with young people at the bottom
outnumbering the elderly at the top
in 1980 there were over three times as
many people in their 20s
as there were in their 60s and this
helped to fuel
china's economic transformation
but these days it's almost neck and neck
this poses a serious problem for china
many analysts think it will overtake
america as the world's largest economy
around the end of this decade but
china's economic growth has actually
slowed in recent years
and a fall in the working age population
could place further strain on the
economy china one of the reasons that it
did so well uh was that it had what
economists referred to as a demographic
dividend
which meant that you had this massive
potential labor force to
staff its factories so china became the
world's biggest manufacturing power
um well now the working age population
is beginning to shrink
which is going to push wages up and
equally for the government
you know it's looking at a pension
system which is
incredibly underfunded right now so the
spending priorities are going to look
very very different
to how they've looked over the past few
decades
the scale of the problem was revealed in
china's once in a decade
census china has released data from its
2020 national census
and it shows the slowest population
growth for decades
the chinese communist party was quick to
act and announced that families would be
able to have three children in the
future
but it may not be enough to encourage a
baby boom
fang and wang are the target audience
for the ccp's campaign to boost the
birth rate
but they are part of the generation
least likely to respond to it
china has changed dramatically since
their parents were growing up
and their expectations from life are
totally different
they have social freedoms that their
parents never enjoyed
they have no memory of a time when
party-run work units called the danwei
allocated their parents jobs and
homes and even gave them approval to get
married
these days marriage and children are not
high on many young people's agenda
in 2005 most women in shanghai were
married by the time they were 23
but in 2019 this had shot up to 29
and most women here will have just one
child as opposed to 2.4
on average worldwide
but for some delaying family isn't a
choice
despite having newfound freedoms some
young people
particularly those working in tech are
still expected to work punishingly long
hours
it's called the 996 because it involves
working
from 9 am to 9 pm 6 days a week
and this doesn't leave much time for
having children
it's 6 30 a.m and on the other side of
town
jeju is getting ready for work she and
her husband ran
routinely work until 10 p.m as well as
caring for their 18 month old
it's not just the 996 the pressure is
high in lots of areas of life
average house prices in shanghai are 23
times
median incomes that's twice the ratio in
london
so anything more than a two-bedroom flat
is well beyond the reach of most
middle-class people
[Music]
juju's parents have moved into their
small flat in shanghai
to care for their granddaughter state
subsidized child care for children under
three
is almost non-existent in china so many
young people rely on their parents or
in-laws for support
given these pressures initiatives like
the three child policy
are unlikely to entice many people to
have more babies
but there are some signs of change
along with the announcement that couples
could have more children
the three-child policy included pledges
to improve maternity benefits
lower the cost of education and improve
state-funded nursing homes
all of which could help boost the birth
rate and improve women's lives
it's clearly a signal to a variety of
ministries in china that they
need to get their act together on this
and start investing
serious money
[Music]
china is trying to turn a very heavy
ship around at the moment
it's going from decades of spending on
infrastructure
to now trying to plow money into
threadbare pension plans
and set up child care facilities that
are simply not there
some fear this demographic conundrum
could jeopardize china's ambition
for global economic dominance but this
might not be the case
as even if china can't encourage its
young people to have more children
it has found other ways to make up for
the shortfall in workers
the first is through automation
china now accounts for about a third of
all industrial robots installed globally
each year
companies are investing heavily in
automation they recognize
that wage costs have been going up that
it's harder and harder to find to
recruit
employees so businesses are becoming
much more digitized
manufacturing is becoming much more
automated
but this isn't just about robots the
workforce is also becoming better
educated
[Music]
since 2010 the number of graduates in
china has doubled
you're going to have a labor force
that's getting smaller
but that's also getting more highly
skilled even if the
size of the workforce shrinks
at least for the next 10 to 15 years
the the increase in the skill set will
more or less
cancel out the decrease in the actual
size of the population
this increased skill set has also
allowed china to move to so-called
higher value economic sectors
so rather than being the workshop of the
world as it was 20 years ago
the country is fast becoming a world
leader in technology
like mobile payments and e-commerce
ran works in electronics and has seen
how quickly
china has progressed on the world stage
against
[Music]
foreign
no longer need to have factories with
thousands of people in them uh instead
you could have
small laboratories that are producing
cutting-edge sciences
so those are the kinds of industries
that china is trying to develop
the final factor driving this
development is the number of people
moving to cities
[Music]
64 of people in china now live in urban
areas
up from less than 50 10 years ago
and this could help because those
working in cities are generally more
productive than rural laborers
but for economic growth to really take
off one aspect of city living
needs to change the grueling 996
when you think about you know
productivity going forward
it's not just about squeezing more out
of every individual worker it's about
having a society
that's happy and a happy society is
likely to be one that's going to be more
innovative
so just having people being stapled to
their desks
trying to crank out code morning to
night that's not a recipe for
a happy productive society in the long
term
here too young people are leading the
way
yuan used to work for a tech firm but
she has recently dropped out to do a phd
as she felt the demands of the 996 just
weren't worth it
[Music]
she and her partner are just two of the
increasing numbers of young people
who are turning away from the rat race
to pursue their own interests
in
[Music]
the pressure is so intense
um and actually it's led to um new slang
in china
najin and it's literally been translated
into english as
turning inward on yourself and it's
meant to
convey the pointlessness of all this
competition that young people feel
they have to engage in yuan and her
partner
are more focused on enjoying life than
having children or working from don to
dusk
but perhaps that need not concern the
ccp
as the odds are that china will be neck
and neck with america
to become the world's largest economy
within the next decade
despite its demographic challenge china
will both
get old and will get rich
at the same time one doesn't necessarily
cancel the other out
but in the future china will need to
invest heavily
in social care both for young children
and the elderly
and this is something the country has
never done before
so while it may not stop china from
getting rich its aging society
will undoubtedly change what it feels
like to live in the world's second
largest economy
i'm stephanie studer the economist china
correspondent
based in beijing if you'd like to read
more about the challenges of china's
aging population
please click the link thank you for
[Music]
watching